[Music]
this is accelerating single-cell
bioinformatics with n dimensional arrays
in the cloud which is a lot the three
important ideas are that single cell
sequencing is a new technology that's
very interesting from the scientific
point of view and it poses some
computational challenges related to
storing and processing array data and
this being 2018 we want to do that in a
way that works on public clouds and is
parallel where appropriate so this work
is being done at relays ursins lab at
mount sinai on a grant from the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative that's part of the
human cell Atlas human cell Atlas is
like a multi-year multi-institution
effort to basically make sense of this
single-cell data that's going to be
increasingly important and proliferated
and you can you can kind of think of it
like the Human Genome Project but like
20 years later and in response to a
different kind of sequencing that's like
being developed in generating
interesting data that we want to
standardize around the processing of and
also my colleague Tom white did in
particular did a lot of the work that
I'm going to be presenting here
okay so agenda is basically I'll
describe the sequencing breakthrough
that's pretty interesting
talk about how we are storing the data
the existing tools are using hdf5 which
is a container format it's been popular
and a lot of scientific domains for like
20 years has some rough edges in the
world of like distributed processing
there's a new technology called Tsar
that we are mostly encouraging adoption
of instead of hdf5 but also doing a lot
of work to try to support both as people
have existing data in hdf5 and so I'll
go into that stuff we want to paralyze
the analysis of this data and there's a
bunch of tools that we've been working
on to do that on various distributed
backends that exists that are pretty
interesting and then I've worked on a n
dimensional array library in Scala for
that implements the Tzar specification
that we're trying to encourage people to
use and that compiles to the JVM and to
JavaScript and will like help to just
have a healthy multi language ecosystem
around this slight format that we're
evangelizing so quick kind of silly
exercise we'll just go through some
basic biology that's relevant to
appreciate the breakthrough on the
scientific side here
so the information that powers life goes
to this process of being in DNA which is
like the cold storage through RNA which
is like more volatile memory like and
ultimately to proteins which like
actually affect the world and at every
stage it's kind of the same information
just encoded in different ways going
from disk to memory you have very
identifiably the same information just
in a different physical substrate you
typically have more information on disk
being stored then you're using at any
given time and an interesting question
is like if you're analyzing a biological
system or a computer system which what
kind of information about which stages
of this process would you like to be
able to read to answer different
questions and there's certain questions
where you'd want to just being able to
see a full snapshot of a disk image of a
machine would be useful in other cases
you'd want to be able to grab what's in
memory and actually being executed and
then the like the actual like pulling
the CPU buffers and registers might be
useful for some things but a little bit
too low-level for other things so to
date we've mostly only had the ability
to read the disk and the memory of cells
and even that with some pretty severe
limitations on what we're able to do and
so some of those limitations are being
lifted and that's kind of the
breakthrough that's happening here so
another kind of like different way to
make a similar analogy is that the DNA
is like all the apps that you have
installed on your computer you might not
be running most of them at any given
time but they're there and given a lot
of machines that were even booted from
the same disk image and have the same
Maps installed they could run different
programs and manifests in the world in
very different ways so you could from
the same pool of like applications
installed you might have a machine
that's behaving like a web server or a
graphic design work
station or a email and video chat client
or a development workstation and then
the things that those running programs
actually do to interact with the world
are analogous to the proteins that
actually comprise different types of
cells that all may all have the same DNA
but they're why very different shapes
and interact with the world in different
ways so that all being said the the
essential breakthrough here that's
assuring and this like this the
animating idea for the human cell atlas
is that we are able to move from bulk
sequencing to single cell sequencing all
of the genome sequencing that you've
heard of to date over the last several
decades has been bulk sequencing we take
a population of cells and we can sample
from the population average of their DNA
or their RNA so you can imagine you're
able to interact with a bunch of servers
and get random snapshots of disk or
memory but you don't really know which
server it came from you have no ability
to like resolve at this at the single
server level it just makes things harder
to identify if there are important
subpopulations of the servers that are
acting as web servers or graphic design
workstations or what have you and so
through some clever chemistry tricks we
are now able to actually say like here
are the exact populations of cells that
exists here are the programs that they
are running and even here's how they are
oriented with with respect to each other
spatially to indicate how they which
types of cells are talking to one
another what types of cells even exists
etc the the clever chemistry trick is
basically a pre-processing stage of the
cells before putting them through the
usual bulk sequencing pipeline and this
pre-processing step essentially puts
every cell into a little oil droplet
along with a bar coding bead that you
kind of just run the cells and the beads
through this in very dilute
concentrations through
like droplet mechanism and most of the
droplets end up empty or they just have
a cell but not a bead or a bead but not
a cell but the important thing is you
will get a maximum of one cell in a
droplet and maximum of one bead in a
droplet and you take the droplets that
where you've had this successful
isolating of a single cell with a single
bead and the bead kind of degrades the
cell and attaches its barcodes to the
cells RNAs so that then when you pool
all the cells back together and you
start sampling from that population all
of your samples have this per cell
barcode attached to them
so that you can now actually say which
RNA reads came from the same cell as
which others that makes sense
and then essentially we cross the
boundary from wet lab to dry lab and
data analysis at this expression matrix
which is basically cells by genes for
every cell how much of each gene did it
express which is like how much of each
program was it running and then from
there we want to cluster the cells and
do a variety of things and for what
profiles of types of applications we're
running on these cells know if I can I
click yeah cool
this is just like a short video of like
kind of what that looks like it's like
like one solitary cell are going through
this pipeline and the thing is just
snapping off droplets and every what's
missing here would be also like the
beads coming through in them getting
snapped into a droplet together but it's
a basic idea cool
so this is the technology to be able to
do this has been maturing over five-ish
years and we've been able to push more
cells through these pipelines and so the
human cell Atlas is a response to that
and you can see just like kind of
exponential increase in the number of
cells the largest data set public data
set now is about a million cells and
we're expecting many more over a period
of years and
everyone's very excited about the
ability to just understand these systems
of cells better by knowing actually what
the specific cell types are and
inferring what they're doing and stuff
okay so then the the data analysis as I
mentioned that the fundamental unit is
basically the expression matrix its
cells by genes and the genes are
basically fixed if you're always looking
at human data there's like 30,000 genes
and then however many cells you want to
push through these experiments so that I
mentioned the largest one is like 1.3
million cells it's like 40 billion
entries but it's mostly sparse so it's
maybe like a billion nonzero entries
like most cells are not expressing most
genes and the two high-level
classifications of kinds of workflows we
want to run are like pre-processing and
quality control normalizing this the
entries in this matrix per per cell or
per gene and then there's the more
interesting downstream stuff is like
different flavors of clustering to
identify what types of cells exist
there's popular tools that exist and
have very healthy open source ecosystems
around them that are written and
maintained by the labs that are doing a
lot of these sequencing experiments and
they've made very high-quality tools
that like do all of the analysis
questions that they want to answer about
this data they're the most popular ones
are written in Python and are and use
different hdf5 schemas as they're like
persistent storage and archival storage
of this data so as these data sets have
grown we want to be able to process them
out of quorum or and so most of the
tools that I was talking about have some
ability to do this so it's been bolted
on a bit they're more used to just
paging the entire data set into memory
and just doing numpy things to it and in
particular we want to be able to process
these things in parallel and in clouds
and hdf5 has some
issues doing that so I've kind of backed
into having to think about this problem
of how to store and process
multi-dimensional array data so hdf5 is
a very interesting project it's been
like standard in the scientific
community for 20 years and widely use
it's basically a way to have like lots
of data in a single file that has like a
virtual file system inside of it and
there's like a directory structure
within this file and then the files
within the file are datasets which are
just multi-dimensional arrays of a given
type and then it has various other like
organically evolved features on top of
that or things can link between each
other and there's a lot of metadata of
different shapes that can be attached to
other things and so there's a lot there
but is based that's the essence of it
it's kind of a side note is that it's
not really a file format it's like a
meta format like you can like in each
scientific domain they'd kind of decide
what they're gonna pass around like
there's kind of like a schema you have
to standardize on of like what
directories with what names and what
data sets with what names do we expect
to find inside of one of these files if
it's geospatial data or single-cell
sequencing or something else so it's
more roughly it's more analogous like
choosing a database system but then
still wanting to standardize around like
what tables and what schemas should
exist in those tables so it's there are
some difficulties that have become worse
over the years I think with using hdf5
it has a very complicated spec and
there's basically one enormous reference
implementation in C that has been
wrapped in many other languages but
you're all you're always essentially
using this one implementation that's by
like the main group that the HT 5 group
and it's not like what I or others would
consider a super-healthy open-source
project like it's not really that
actively developed widely in the
community or like doesn't have good like
issue tracker kind of just doesn't feel
like the kind of ecosystem that I'm more
used to and comfortable working with and
in particular the the C implementation
like does No
it only reads from local files so all
these other languages like Python has
good libraries for interacting with
Google Cloud storage or s3 but you can't
inject those anywhere because you're
just calling this C library that's like
hard coding like local file system i/o
we and others have tried to use fused
adapters to get around that and they
never seem to really work and it's kind
of not really the way you'd want to do
this anyway so it's just kind of hard to
deal with and then the the parallel
processing story is also limited partly
by just being stuck with the local file
system and also the idea of having these
large data sets be just single files on
an underlying file system poses problems
for how you would like write one of
these things with like a thousand way
parallelism like you that's just like
not really feasible in most file system
like environments so there's kind of an
emerging consensus in several scientific
domains that are wanting to use
something that's a little more natively
parallel and cloud friendly than hdf5 so
ZAR is the thing that we've been most
excited about it's a it's a new much
simpler implementation of the same kind
of idea you have like groups and
datasets that are roughly like
directories and files it can be nested
and in ends are the files or data sets
are themselves a directory on some
underlying file system but you could use
just an arbitrary key value store
instead of a file system here but you
can see in the lower right what a two
dimensional array looks like on disk in
ZAR it was like Zr a metadata file that
shows you the shape of the two
dimensional array and the shape of the
chunks that is partitioned into and
other information about the compression
that's been used which is pluggable and
so and then you have like the files that
are each chunk two chunks on each axis
four chunks total and those chunk files
are just like ten by ten signed integers
in this case so it's just like 400 bytes
run through Z Lib and that's the file
it's fairly like straightforward how do
act with this and you can easily
parallel write these things cuz like
just a worker can just write one chunk
very easily and likewise to read them so
it's a very simple spec it removes a lot
of cruft
from hdf5 it's a reference
implementation in Python and then
there's independent implementations in
C++ and I've worked on one in Scala that
compiles to the JVM into JavaScript like
I mentioned and it's it's a new and
exciting community is not like baggage
and legacy code that we have to worry
about so we can just kind of make it be
what we want it to be on the other hand
it's like missing essential tooling in
some cases that we need to write which
will become our baggage and legacy code
someday but it will be ours um and well
suited to our particular use case I
guess it's being somewhat officially
adopted by the human cell Atlas for
storing and processing this data so one
other like notable entity in this space
is the common data model and the
implementation main implementation of it
called called netcdf which is an
existing years old pretty established
standard that's like also a kind of
simplified abstraction over hdf5 and
other things like it that have this like
nested groups and data sets that are
multi-dimensional arrays kind of
structure some amount of extra features
on top of that it's like basically a
subset of hdf5 or like kind of not
technically and there's just some but it
is interesting because there isn't a
java implementation that works for all
of these backends including the parts of
hdf5 that are supported by this common
data model so it's kind of like a second
implementation of the hdf5 spec with
just some of it so it'll be relevant
later cool so I'll just talk about what
we've done so far and where we're going
so we want all these single-cell tools
to be able to use our instead of hdf5
possibly in addition to we've added
support for ZAR to scan pi which is one
of the popular single-cell tools and
that's merged in and released
so it can read and write czar files in
cloud storage some low-hanging
optimizations around how light cloud
store seeks are slow and you know more
work to be done there so it's not like
the main path that people would want to
use yet but then and then some of the
other tools are written in our and
haven't totally figured out our story
for leveraging some of the same work or
in over there or just redoing it in our
in some sense
we've also done some work to improve the
tooling around hdf5 and try to see if it
can be made better before trying to tell
everyone to just switch this other thing
or just ideally have an abstraction
where they don't have to worry about
which of them that they're using so Tom
my colleague took this the Java
implementation of the parts of hdf5 that
conform to the common data model spec
and swapped in the Java and i/o
interface underneath its file system IO
and there are Google Cloud and Amazon s3
adapters implementations of the Java and
i/o interface so we can read and write h
t5 files in these clouds which to my
knowledge is the only place where that
capability has existed and then he also
puts mark bindings on top of that so we
can at least read from these hdf5 files
that have like chunk arrays inside them
we can just drop workers at specific
places inside this giant file we've
split up and make it look like a
essentially a Hadoop input format or a
mark friendly parallel read path so
that's cool it's also like yeah not
super optimized and not really something
we think is going to make that much
sense long term but important technical
diligence I think to do at the very
least so we want to make all these
analyses run in parallel also Tom
created this library called zappy which
is just like a numpy array interface
that is backed by a variety of
interesting distributed processing
engines so pi ren is basically just AWS
lambdas if you haven't seen it it's a
very interesting project like you give
it your array and the transformation you
want to apply and it just forms that out
to infinity lambdas and then connect
collects the result back so I'm really
like excited about that as a paradigm
going forward and then
more standard like server full
distributed engines like spark and beam
and you can run it in local mode too so
it's a cool abstraction and library and
it's also released in this one in this
Python single cell library scan pi and
then here's like some benchmarks running
it with spark that just are kind of
three different views on the same
underlying idea which is like if you you
know hold the job duration fixed and you
can increase the number of cores and
increase the number of cells or if you
hold the cores fixed you can get a
greater speed up versus a single node
version by running on more cells or if
you hold the cells in the data set fixed
then you can reduce the job duration by
adding more cores and there's some
amount of fixed costs to lifting into
the distributed paradigm and as there
always is but you know it's about the
kinds of trade-offs that we would expect
and we think it's good to give people
the option at least to distribute these
jobs tasks is kind of the original
version of this trick which is like it's
it looks like an umpire array but we're
gonna like run it on a distributed way
on a big or medium kubernetes cluster
and we're going to make that very easy
and so we've added support for that to
scan PI as well so this is this
libraries something I've been working on
which is a Xaro implementation in Scala
that also wraps this Java hdf5 common
data model implementations so we can
convert data sets from hdf5 to tsar
directly in the cloud in parallel it's
because I'm compiling my Scala to Jade
JVM bytecode and to JavaScript
I have a web app where I can just read
the Tzar data directly like in the
browser and have just a completely
static thing it could even run some of
these conversions if you wanted to and I
don't have to ever see any of your data
or anything or it can proxy the server
and I think that that portability is
just is interesting in general and I
kind of went crazy with some like type
system and functional programming things
in this Scala library where it's like
uses higher kinda types that you can
plug in different multi-dimensional
array implementations and
parallelization engines and it's
typesafe in the number of array
dimensions so it knows if you are
dealing with a four dimensional array or
a three dimensional array and few index
four dimensions deep in a three
dimensional array will be a compiled
compiler error and it's kind of using
the implicit resolution mechanism of the
Scala compiler as a kind of formal
verification so it's like a style of
programming where you're kind of telling
the compiler here are your functions
that take certain types to other types
and here's the types I'm starting with
and here's the type I'd like to get to
and like you figure it out
so like program synthesis kind of thing
which is like hard but may be good for
something so anyway if that's
interesting to you I'm happy to talk
about that afterwards so stuff we'll be
doing next we want to benchmark on
bigger datasets I think there will be
public datasets that are larger soon
probably but we might just synthesize
some in the meantime I like just taking
the million cell data set and
concatenating it with itself a bunch of
times we want to push further in the
processing pipelines some of this
parallel and cloud friendliness to date
we've mostly done like pre-processing
and QC steps that are more like map
stages than shuffle stages but it's like
clustering and distributed search and
indexing things that we'll want to do
especially as there are just like more
cells in the world that we want to be
able to analyze and so those algorithms
will be interesting and paralyzing it
should be interesting challenge the nd
array Scala library I mentioned has just
a lot of basic stuff that I need to
finish to get to like a vo1
one thing I'm very excited about is that
in addition to targeting like the JVM
and JavaScript there's a native Scala
project a nascent Scala project called
Scala native that compiles Scala code to
native code
so that you can interrupt with C
libraries and even have other things
interrupt interact with this compiled
outputs as native code and then we need
to also give some of the same treatment
to some of the are based tools probably
the easiest way to do that is just
inject a spark our layer into them but
it would be nice to reuse some of these
other abstractions we've created that
allow for using different
parallelization engines and stuff there
is precedent and some of these are tools
for like shelling out to a Java jar for
some things that aren't implemented in
our there's also precedent for removing
that because it was gross and yeah it
would be cool if I could compile my
Scala library it's a native code that I
could call from our that seemed that
might be totally insane but I'll
probably try it at some point yeah okay
so summary trying to make this the
storage and processing of this
single-cell data more cloud friendly and
parallel there's a couple existing tools
we want to work with they span a couple
languages which poses interesting
challenges and there's also multiple
good parallelization engines on the
market that we want to be able to
support the simple stages we've done so
far are scaling about as you'd expect
some of these things are embarassingly
parallel and we can embarassingly
paralyze them and it works pretty good
pretty well and then two interesting
libraries that we've made as part of
this are zappy which is this interface
for a bunch of parallelization engines
over numpy like arrays similar to what
desk is already pretty well known for
doing and then this Scala and D array
library that supports hdf5 and czar and
has some interesting type safety
properties associated with it so that's
all for me I'll take questions if we
have time
are
okay interesting questions how much
better is our than hdf5 depending what
you want to do it could be infinitely
better because it lets us do things that
we just can't do with age of five
I mean subjects you the caveat that you
could write in hdf5 library that plays
more nicely at the clouds and stuff I
don't know but it's it's really
complicated to do that and the path of
least resistance so far is to just do
something that's simpler slightly from
scratch and it's interesting part of the
story is that czar has now connected
with the like common data model folks
and they're just kind of like this looks
like it should just be one of our many
backends to this like unified model of
like these multi-dimensional group and
data set structures so probably what
will happen is it will it'll just be
that it will become like that cdf will
be like this abstraction over these
kinds of meta formats for storing this
data or whatever so and then your second
question was is it close to optimal for
some things certainly today probably not
I mean I know that you know we're really
focused on kind of like this like higher
level like let's just like you know
we're already in like the spark realm
where we're not like pinching CPU cycles
or being like you're not being very
precious with our resources it's more
just like can we just like put more
machines at the problem and know that at
least we can easily scale and then we'll
optimize it later as we need which is
like a choice not always the right
choice by any stretch for depending on
your context but I don't know if that's
yes
okay so the questions about like just
overheads that exist with Zack with desk
for serializing and deserializing those
things also exist with spark for sure
and it's a pain point and there's like
lots of you know people that run
benchmarks were like okay I can just
take her do this computation on one
machine or like a hundred note smart
cluster and so you can definitely get
into the situation you have to track
those overheads and I know particularly
like PI spark has introduced an extra
layer of that historically and had worse
performance than like the JVM native
spark bindings there's a lot of spark
2.0 is like mitigating that so that the
same the data in the buffers that goes
over the wire is like used in place and
they're managing their own memory and so
that's like one way that a lot of these
systems get around it the aro project is
also relevant for doing things like that
so the short answer is like we're just
you know piggybacking on what exists in
the ecosystem around that and like yeah
you have to if it's a small data set or
like you're willing to wait longer but
you really don't you really want to
minimize the number of CPU cycles you
pay for then like probably don't use all
this heavy machinery for it right
is it too early to ask how much adoption
these things have gotten never too early
to ask I think one thing we're trying to
really do is just like play nicely with
the tools that everyone's already using
and so in the sense that these things
are already released in scan pi that's
like a good I don't at least probably
one third of the actual like people in
scientific context that are running
these tools are they using the you know
setting the flags to do this stuff
today I would guess not but I think some
of this is forward-looking we expect the
data sizes to grow it's still at the
stage where like if you follow the
github rebus for these tools there's
like a steady cadence of people coming
by and being like oh I tried to run it
out on this 1 million cell dataset
unlike a machine that had 500 gigabytes
of RAM in the cloud and I still seem
like it ran into some memory pressure
and you know people are still trying to
make it work
with the data set sizes they have on the
single node model I don't think that
they're aware or necessarily that
interested right now at incurring the
overhead of using these more complicated
tools which is probably correct but if
the data set sizes get 10 times bigger
then they'll probably have to and so we
want to be ready for that and also but
if we optimize this stuff more it could
be like more clearly just better now for
the stuff that's on the larger side
today
very large is
have people not been generating the
larger data sets because the tool room
was not there to process him a great
question and that's I've done a lot of
like trying to go into these
bioinformatics contexts and be like
let's at least have the option to
process larger data because we would
probably start asking different
questions and doing different science
potentially if we did I'm just kind of
like I mean whatever it's it's a
self-serving stick in some ways but I
think it's true it's hard to
characterize this negative space of
where we're not looking I think for sure
that's the case like some of these
analyses that people run today the first
thing they do is just like put some hard
cut-offs on the kinds of genes and cells
they want to look at to just reduce the
data sizes by 10x or 100x to make it
just more tenable and they're probably
right like this probably was the least
interesting 90 percent of the data but
it's like it wasn't done because it was
like good science is done partly due to
computational constraints I don't think
that all the way at the top of the
funnel here at the sequencing level
they're sequencing less due to this
there's definitely still like there's
like an arms race to see who can like
it's a pride and prestige thing and it
is very impressive to like run these
assays at this kind of scale so to the
extent which anyone is going to be able
to do a 10 million cell data set I'm
sure they're racing to do that and then
the tools as they currently exist would
probably just start by dropping a bunch
of the data and then just working on
what's left or something naively
[Music]